[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ولدت في سان فرانسيسكو لاسره
فلسطينيه مهاجره وحتى العاشره لم تكن تعرف
شيئا عن فلسطين والعروبه سوى انتمائها
وجذورها فقط استشعر والدها الخطر انذاك
واختار العوده بابنائه الى رام الله في
محاوله منه لاكسابهم اللغه والدين والهويه
كما يجب حينها فقط بدات ضيفتنا الدكتوره
اماني جمال تعلم اللغه العربيه كما يجب
ولم تكن بحاجه لجهد كبير في استعادته
هويتها الفلسطينيه كما اراد والداها
فالحواجز الاسرائيليه والقمع والصعوبات
التي يتعرض لها الناس هناك ومنهم هي سرعت
من تحقيق الهدف وزادت عليه بان اصبحت
البروفيسورا جمال فلسطينيه كما يجب اتمت
الثانويه في فلسطين وانتزعت منها مره اخرى
للولايات المتحده درست العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه كاليفورنيا في مدينه لوس انجلوس عام
93 من القرن الماضي ثم اكملت الماجستير
والد في حقول العلوم السياسيه عام 2002 في
جامعه الشهيره تقول للدكتور عماني عندما
اقوم بتدريس مسار السياسه في الشرق الاوسط
فانما اقوله هو اننا سنقوم بتفكيك
المفاهيم الخاطئه التي لديك عن الاخر ايا
كان هذا الاخر مما يشير بشكل جليل همها
العربي والفلسطيني وبقت تعانيه امراه
مسلمه ومحجبه وفلسطينيه في المجتمع
الاكاديمي الغربي فلم يكن طريقها خاليه من
العنصريه وازدراء الاخر او التخوف منه على
الاقل وتشير للسؤال المتكرر حتى بين
الاوساط الليبراليه لماذا ترتدي الحجاب
والذي اعتبر دليلا على تشددها وتتذكر
البروفيسوره جمال تعرضها لتمييز وعنصريه
عندما تواصلت مع استاذ علوم سياسيه شهير
للتعبير عن رغبتها في دراسه الدكتوراه تحت
اشرافه الا انه رفض ان يقبلها في البرنامج
وقال انه لا يحب ان يعمل مع طالبه متشدده
بهذا الشكل
البروفيسور اماني جمل عميد كليه الشؤون
العامه والدوليه في جامعه برينستون
واستاذه كرسي ادوارد سعيد في جامعه
سانفورد للعلوم السياسيه واستاذه العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
برينستر الشهيره ضيفه المقابله في الحلقه
الاولى فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا دكتور الله يخليك
دكتور اماني جمال عميده كليه الشؤون
الدوليه في جامعه ايوه هذا المنصب منصب
اكاديمي رفيع الله يخليك حصلتي عليه مؤخرا
مؤخرا سنه ونص قاتلتي كثيرا للحصول على
المنصب
الحمد لله اجانا من من يعني
العلوم السياسيه التخصصي الشرق الاوسط
والحمد لله
الجامعه يعني
وبعدين حكوا لي انه انت من
المؤهلين
معك مقابله بين اربع مرشحين اربع مرشحين
من بجوز خلال فوق 100 شخص كيف خلينا نرجع
شويه لاماني جمال الطفله الفلسطينيه
المولوده في سان فرانسيسكو ايوه
متى هاجرت الاسره الوالد لما كان ابوي
وامي هاجروا في الالف
وقت الحرب في فلسطين طلعوا على امريكا
انا ولدت في امريكا انت الاكبر من بين
الاولاد
اختي دكتوره علوم سياسيه في جامعه جيمز
مارسين في واشنطن
تربينا فلسطينيه
اطباء ومهندسين اكيد صاروا في هذا الموضوع
التخصص لا ما هو انا اول اول ما دخلت
الجامعه على اساس بدي ادرس طب زيي زي
الفلسطينيه في الغالب معظم العرب
بالحصص العلميه
والوقت الطويل زهقت كنت كثير يعني لا كنت
كنت كثير يعني رغبتي اني ادرس علوم سياسيه
وانا اقرا عن سيره الدكتوره اماني جمال
كنت لا تتحدثي العربيه لا تعرفين اللغه
العربيه وانا كنت صغيره
لما روحنا على فلسطين
[موسيقى]
ولد هيك يعني انه دائما كان يعني الهدف
والامنيه انه يعني يجي على امريكا يحوش
فلوس ويرجع يربينا بفلسطين ولما صار عمرنا
عشر سنين يعني حكى انه هذا الوقت المناسب
انه نرجع على فلسطين قرار صعب يا اول مره
حلنا من امريكا على فلسطين يعني هلا الدول
العربيه وفلسطين الاردن كذا يعني
تمشي فيهم بتشوف انه يعني بجوز الحاجز بين
الغرب والشرق الاوسط مش زي ما كانت بال
1980 يعني حسينا انه طلعنا من امريكا وعلى
غربه
فش حدا بحكي اللغه المدارس مختلفه التعليم
مختلف
صرنا نتعرف على ناس كنا نعرفهم انه قلنا
اهل بس ما نعرفهمش فصار عندي خالات وعمات
واولاد عمام وبلاد خالاتهم اتعرف عليهم
احنا من قدر الله
فلاحي من
الفلاحيه الحمد لله الحمد لله
[ضحك]
من سنه 80 من 1980 لحد الانتفاضه لحد
الانتفاضه الاولى شو اللي حصل بالنسبه
لطالبه فلسطينيه
ولدت في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وعاشت
لبلدها الاصليه شو اللي يتغير عليك يعني
اولها كان كثير صعب يعني كنت لما بتفطن
يعني شغلات بسيطه لقيت طفل انه كنا في
امريكا نتفرج على التلفزيون كان طول
النهار لما روحنا على فلسطين في كان لسه
ست ساعات
ثلاث ساعات وكلهم بالعربي احنا جايين من
امريكا يعني كان انه يعني في الم انه
مشتاقين لامريكا كاطفال يعني كاطفال بس
لما صرنا لما انا يعني صرت افهم الوضع
السياسي وافهم الوضع اللي في بلدنا يعني
صار عندي انتماء وصار عندي انه طيب انا
يعني مزبوط يعني بديش اكون انانيه اضل عن
حياه اللي كانت في امريكا وانا الطفله وكل
الشعب الفلسطيني ما عندهم تلفزيونات في
احتلال يعني عيب ونقاط تفتيش وحواجز
يعني اول مره لما رحنا على المدرسه كنت
بصف السادس لما لما يعني وجهت حقيقه
الاحتلال كنت كتير يعني في امريكا طبعا
تروح بالباص على المدرسه وبترجع عادي امنه
جيده وفي يوم كنا بالباس وقف في الباص
وعبر الجيش على الباص واعترف الجيش
الاسرائيلي وكان كثير يعني انا كنت كتير
يعني يعني
مصدومه يعني فيلم شو يعني مش حقيقي
ويسيحوا وانه افتحوا شنطاتكم بدنا نفتشكم
انا مش فاهم اللي صاير فهذا هاي كانت يعني
بجوز اول اول
خبره يعني انه انه في احتلال
انا كنت في مدرسه الفرينس يعني فيها قسم
انجليزي وكيسم عربي مش بس قسم انجليزي
وكان كان عنا استاذ بالبيت كمان يجينا كل
يوم ساعه ساعه ونص للغه العربيه وللاسلام
والدين والقران بعدين صرتي سعيده بانك
تعلمت العربيه الحمد لله يعني لو عاد بك
الزمن كان هذا خيار اني اتعلم العربي من
انا قبل العشر سنين الان حينما عدتي وعادت
فلسطينيه او تشكلت هويتك الفلسطينيه وشفتي
حال فلسطين تحت نير الاحتلال شو اللي
اختلف مع الدكتور المجتمع الامريكاني بهتم
بالطفل
ومجتمعنا الفلسطيني كمان بهتم بالطفل بس
الاحتلال بعطيش حقوق الاطفال هاي لما انا
روحت وشفت انه في الاضطهاد هذا موجود وانه
الاتحاد هذا يعني مش عدل طبعا هاي بتكون
هويتك انه ايش طب ليش انا ادرس طب وبقدر
ادرس علوم سياسيه وافيد وطني وتكوني
مشتبكه مع الواقع الواقع وافهم يعني كيف
كيف الواحد بقدر من من ناحيه اكاديميه او
التعليميه انه يساعد ويفهم شو القضيه شو
الحلول شو شو اللي بنقدر احنا نسوي كشعب
عربي يعني لما رجعت لامريكا
لا اول شيء جينا على كاليفورنيا
داخل طب اه بعدين اخذت انت هون لازم تاخذ
لازم تاخذ حصص اليكتفز مواد اخرى لازم
تاخذي مواد بالعلوم السياسيه فانا سجلت
انا كنت زهقان من الطب واخذت حصص بالعلوم
السياسيه اجى انا كنت متحجبه بالالف
وتسعمائه بجوز في كل الجامعه انا كنت
المتحجبه الوحيده انا اتحجبت كان عمري 19
سنه انا تحجبت لا لا لا
انا
كنت بفلسطين ما تحجبتش لما رجعت بعد
الانتفاضه على امريكا يعني كان كتير انا
عندي ماساه انه كيف احنا لانه احنا
انولدنا في امريكا انه احنا محظوظين معنا
الهويه الامريكانيه
يعني احنا لما انت عارف الانتفاضه الاولى
سكروا كل المدارس والجامعات فهايو كل
الطلاب سواء كانوا كنتوجين
اللي هو كله كله وقف والجامعه
قاعد في البيت احنا الحمد لله لانه معنا
ابوي قال يلا امي وابوي الله امريكا
لما انت بتطلع بالماساه هاي وبتدشر يعني
اصدقائي صاحباتي my con يطلعوا بتضل انت
حامل ولو انه احنا ذنب انه ولو احنا ما
احنا يعني انا يعني ما جبتش الدم هذا نفسي
مش مش مسؤوله ولو كل ما نقعد احنا
بالجامعه ولا في حصه وكلا ما شاء الله
نظيف ولايك اتذكر انه كل زملائي وصحباتي
كثير
سؤالي عن الحجاب حتى لا يلتبس الامر طبعا
الحجاب قرار ديني وفي جانب اجتماعي وهو
قرار شخصي لكن كانه كان قرار ايضا لاماني
جمال قرار هويتي له علاقه بالهويه تريدين
ان تبدوين كعربيه كمسلمه كفلسطينيه الحمد
لله دائما كان عندنا دين وبنصوم وبنصلي
والحمد لله بس لما جيت على امريكا حسيت
انه كل الناس عندهم اول اشي فكره سيئه عن
الاسلام والمسلمين فكنت اقعد بالصف
الاسلام والمسلمين لهم انا مسلمه انا من
دين الاسلام انا فلسطينيه دائما اني اضل
اوضح شو الوضع الان احنا في هذه عمرها
قرنين حوالي قرنين حوالي قرنين هي واحده
من اعظم الجامعات الامريكيه في العالم
الحمد لله الحمد لله عميده كليه الشؤون
العامه والدوليه في هذا ماذا يعني بالنسبه
لاماني جمال هذا الامر يعني شوف انا لما
الحمد لله يعني لما انت سالتني انه انت
حبيتي تاخذي هالوظيفه الحمد لله
يعني ما سالتش عن الوظيفه هاي مهتمه
وباحثه والحمد لله مبسوطه كتير
بس لما اجت الفرصه
الكليه مسؤوليه اداره وبدك تحمل مسؤوليه
بدك يعني زي امانه في رقبتك بدك
تشتغل تعملها كما يجب والحمد لله انا يعني
كنتش محتاج شغل زياده الحمد لله كان في
صعوبات حينما تم تعيينك في المنصب بمعنى
هل اثير سؤال المحجبه الفلسطينيه المهاجره
ولا حدا سال اشي لانه انا اليام عشرين سنه
في العشرين خارج الجامعه ما سمعتش كثير
وداخل الجامعه بيعرفوني يعني بيعرفوني
فلسطينيه اني مسلمه انه في اشياء يعني
بيعرفوني انا يعني بمشي على ديني يعني
عارفين
ليش يعني احنا بنصلي بنصوم في رمضان يعني
بنكون صايمين بروح على الاجتماعات ما
بتغداش معهم طبعا لما نطلع على الدينام
انا طبعا احنا بنشربش كمسلمين يعني
بيعرفوا يعني انه يعني دائما
بكل الطلاب المسلمين اللي بيكونوا خايفين
بيكونوا خايفين يقولوا انهم هم مسلمين انه
هيني انا الي عشرين سنه
عمري ما شعرت اني لازم اغير من مبادئي من
شان يحترموك اكثر دكتوره رسايل بوجودك
الله يخليك ننتقل لطاوله الحوار ان شاء
الله لدينا قضايا كثيره مع الدكتوره اماني
جمال عميله كليه الشؤون العامه والدوليه
في جامعه برينستون قضايا كثيره ومسؤوله
الباروميتر العربي ومؤلفه الكتب التي لها
علاقه بالديمقراطيه عقبات ديمقراطيه في
العالم العربي الامبراطوريه والمواطنين
وغير ذلك من قضايا اهلا وسهلا شرفتونا
عقبه العرب الكاؤود لعل هذا هو التوصيف
الذي يتخذه اغلب المشتغلين بعلوم السياسه
منطلقا لدراساتهم بشان الديمقراطيه في
المنطقه قبل ان يشرعوا في تحليل اسباب
الاستعصاء لكل منهم في ذلك مسلكه اسفر
النظام العالمي المتشكل بعد انتهاء الحرب
العالميه الثانيه منتصف اربعينيات القرن
الماضي عن استقلال الدول العربيه وجلاء
المستعمر حدث ذلك بالتوازي مع ثورات
وحركات عسكريه وضعت حدا للنظم الوراثيه
التي حكمت دولا واسنا كمصر والعراق
والسوريه وليبيا
بثه النظم الناشئه اعمالا عريضه في وجدان
الشعوب بما قطعت على نفسها من وعود بارساء
قيم العدل والمساواه وتعزيز الحريات لكن
الوجوه الوادعه التي الت اليها الامور في
تلك الدول وبعدما سوقت نفسها بشعارات بعثت
الامل في الجماهير سرعان ما اظهرت عصا
غليظه لكل مخالف منقلبه على كل الوعود
وبعد شعار الاشتراكيه المسيطر في
الخمسينيات والستينيات جاءت الثمانينات
والتسعينات مقترنه بمصطلح الليبراليه الذي
لم يتعدى حظ العرب منه بعضا من انفتاح
الاقتصادي وبرلمانات افرغت من المضمون
الحقيقي للمجالس المنتخبه كما عرفتها
النظم الديمقراطيه
جاء الربيع العربي فتجددت الامال في ارساء
الديمقراطيه تضيق الفجوه بين الشرق والغرب
لكن الامل لم يطل وحدثت الانتكاس سريعا
ليعود العرب من حيث بداوا ولتعلوا الى حين
اصوات ما فتات تصحيح في وجوههم بان
الديمقراطيه لا تصلح لهذا المكان
مرحبا بك مجددا الدكتوره مرحبا
اريد ان اتعرف على مشوارك الاكاديمي انت
درستي البكالوريوس في العلوم السياسيه ثم
ايضا تخصصتي في الماجستير والدكتوراه في
جامعه بماذا تخصصتي في العلوم السياسيه
تخسست بالتنميه السياسيه والديمقراطيه في
الدول العربيه الدول العربيه تحديدا لماذا
لانه كان يعني احنا بنعرف انه كل الدول
بالعالم ما كانتش من اولها الديمقراطيه
انه الدول العالم كلها يعني تبعت مشوار
خطه فيها تنميه سياسيه وبعدين اصبحت
ديمقراطيه فانه احنا بدنا نشوف انه هل
هل موجوده بالدول العربيه وكيف انا رح
نمشي على مشوار الديمقراطيه ماذا وجدتي في
العالم العربي ايه كوارث وجدتي يعني دائما
احنا بنحكي على الكوارث العربيه طبعا في
كوارث ولكن وجدنا انه يعني
كان من
من
مفاهيم الاساسيه انه نقصد الديمقراطيه
بالدول العربيه انه شو السبب انه الشعوب
العربيه بدهاش ديمقراطيه هذا كان المفهوم
الانطباع الذهني الذهني هون في امريكا
طبعا كانت مبنيه على ايش لا تريد او لا
تستحق لا تريد ما بتقدرش الديمقراطيه ايش
كان هذا مبني على انه اساس انه انه الشرق
الاوسط فيها حروب كان فيها ارهاب كانوا
يرجعوا على كم من يعني حلقه ارهابيه
ويقولوا ان الدول العربيه ما عندهاش
المبادئ معندهاش
الاسس السياسه او مجتمع دمقراطي وانا كنت
ادرس
دكتوراه كنت اشوف انه هذا هاي المفاهيم
كلها غلط انا تربيت انا تربيت في الدول
العربيه وانا يعني بنت عرب وكنت عارف انه
كل القصص اللي كانوا يحكوا عنها انه
احترام الديمقراطيه حقوق الانسان انه
فيكون في في مجتمعات بتحب بعضها طبعا
مزبوط كان موجود ولكن انه ايش الحكومات ما
كانش الديمقراطيه فبدنا نفهم احنا
كباحثين انه تمشوه ليش ليش انه يعني انه
كيف انه
الاستطلاعات الراي العامه العربيه يعني
بتتواجد مع انه الحكومات هاي العربيه اللي
مش ديمقراطيه فهذا اللي انا بلشت انا يعني
المشوار اللي مشيت عليه في حياه
الاكاديميه في اكثر من بلد عربي
اول دراسه قمتها في فلسطين كانت وقت وقت
الاتفاقات وتسعين
في عمليه الدكتوراه ب 96 كانت لسه انه ايش
السلطه موجوده وانه ان الحركه السياسيه
السلميه ماشيه وان راح تصير
ديمقراطيه والدولتين الدوله الاسرائيليه
والدوله فلسطينيه وانه الدوله الفلسطينيه
راح تكون ديمقراطيه كتير مهتمين الغرب
انها تكون الدوله الجديده الفلسطينيه انها
لسبب هذا حطوا الانتخابات قبل ما كان في
دوله صار انتخابات قبل ما في دوله وانه
لازم لازم الشعب الفلسطيني
يثبت انه شعب ديمقراطي قبل انها الخطه
السياسيه السلميه راح تستمر ولذلك صارت
انتخابات وصاروا يدعموا المجتمع المدني
مؤسسات المدنيه انه ايش لازم تكون مؤسسه
الديمقراطيه ومش اسلاميه
فهذا كان الخوف على مقاس الغربي الغربي
فانا لما بلشت ادرس
لما بلشت بالابحاث
الدكتوراه بدي افهم انه هالدعم اتجاه
الديمقراطيه بفلسطين هل راح يحقق نتيجه
ديمقراطيه بدون ما ناخد
الواقع بكل يعني بكل منصب من السياسه من
الاحتلال من الحكومه ايفل حكومه السلطه
وفتح انه شو هذا بيعني للشعب الفلسطيني
فكان اول بحث انه
يعني الكتاب الفته اللي
عن الديمقراطيه عن المجتمع المدني
الفلسطيني وقت فرصه اصله فقط في فلسطين او
درستي ايضا بلدان عربيه اخرى
فلسطين بس كنت يعني كان في يعني زي ما
تسوي بالاردن بالمغرب
لكن في مصر الكويت في الكتاب الثاني درسته
طيب ما هي الاشياء الكلمات المفتاحيه التي
تبحثون عنها لفهم مساله الديمقراطيه في
العالم العربي ما هي الموضوعات الاساسيه
من زاويه المجتمع المجتمع المدني يعني في
زاويه مجتمع مدني وطبعا من
الارجنت من المجتمع المدني او يعني
من من اسس الكي كي ار المجتمع المدني انه
الحياه الديمقراطيه معتمده على مجتمع مدني
مجتمع انه
بحب انه يشارك بالحياه اليوميه والسياسيه
في مجتمعه بحب يساعد بحب انه
[موسيقى]
يتطوعوا انه يكونوا مسؤولين عن
الاشياء اللي بتخص اليوس طبعا الشباب
الشباب بالمجتمعات لما انا بلشت يعني
بالابحاث وصرت اني هالشغلات موجوده كيف في
المجتمع المدني مبني بالدول العربيه
كثير حياتنا اليوميه نتطوع اذا ما طوعناش
بشغلنا اوعنا بالمجتمع كمان احنا العائلات
والمناسبات العائ والالتزامات العائليه
هذا كله يعني يعتبر من نوعا ما من التطوع
بس دكتوره في فلسطين كيف يمكن دراسه واقع
الديمقراطيه في مجتمع تحت الاحتلال يعني
مقومات الدوله الاساسيه لم تتوفر فما بالك
عن مقومات المجتمع المدني
يعني النقطه هاي كنت بدي لازم يعني انه
تحايل لايت للاكاديميه انه ما عندكش كل
القصص للدوله
الديمقراطيه ساره ايش انت يعني يعني مع
احترامي لك
لما حكت عن الدوله الفلسطينيه وليش الدوله
الفلسطينيه مش ماشيه واول شيء حكت انه
المانيا كانت ديمقراطيه قبل ما امريكا ما
دعمتها بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه انه
كان في خطه ديمقراطيه وان الفلسطينيه لازم
يبنوا مجتمع مدني ديمقراطي قبل ما نحكي عن
دوله ويعني نشوف المفهوم كيف عكسوها فاحنا
كنا انا يعني طالب الدكتوره كنت يعني
اناقش انه اذا ما كانش في
اسس الدوله موجوده والحريات والدوله تكون
يعني مستقله انه منقدرش نحكي عن الخطوات
اللي بتؤدي للديمقراطيه وهي مش موجوده
متوفره
مع انتهاء كل عام دراسي يتخرج الاف الطلبه
العرب الدارسين في جامعه اوروبا وامريكا
الشماليه اما بنفقات شخصيه وعائليه او من
خلال برامج الابتعاث التي تشرف عليها
حكومات بلادهم ووفق التقارير الامميه
وتقارير المعهد الدولي للتعليم فان نحو
100 الف من الطلاب العرب يلتحقون سنويا
بجامعات امريكيه وكنديه واوروبيه
واستراليه مشكلين ما نسبته 6% من الطلبه
المغتربين بالجامعات الغربيه التي يشغل
الطلبه الصينيون النسبه الاكبر منها
لكن وبحسب التقارير نفسها فان 82% من
الطلاب الصينيين يعودون الى بلادهم بينما
لا تتعدى نسبه طلبه العرب العائدين الى
دولهم خمسه في المئه ويمكن تقسيم الطلبه
العربي الى ثلاث مجموعات اولها المغتربون
القادمون مباشره من مواطنهم الاصليه ثم
المغتربون من ابناء العاملين في الدول
الخليجيه وانتهاء بابناء الجيل الثاني من
المهاجرين العربي في الغرب الذين يحملون
جنسيات دول نشاتهم وهاؤلاء لا تشملهم
التقارير الامميه الدوليه
الاحصاءات الرسميه العربيه تشير الى تصدر
كل من السعوديه والكويت وفلسطين والاردن
لكن هذه الاحصاءات يغيب عنها الدارسون على
نفقاتهم الخاصه او بمنح غربيه وهي فئه
تمثل سنويا نحو 36 الفا من جنسيات مختلفه
اغلبهم من مصر والمغرب وتونس والجزائر
وبينما تفرز الكويت وقطر والامارات العدد
الاكبر من الدارسين بالجامعات البريطانيه
والكنديه تتفوق المغرب والجزائر وتونس في
عدد الطلبه بالجامعات الاوروبيه
والفرانكفونيه في حين تحظى كل من قطر
والكويت بالنصيب الاكبر من الدارسين العرب
في جامعات القمه بالولايات المتحده
بعد ما انتهيت من الدكتوراه اول جامعه
تعينت فيها بريستون اول جامعه كولومبيا
كولومبيا في نيويورك وهي ايضا واحده من
اهم الجامعات الحلقات الدوليه كم استمرت
سنه في سنه واحده لماذا لم تطيل المقام
طبعا كلهم يتكلم عن ادوارد سعيد اتكلم عن
وكانوا كلهم الله يرحمه وكان موجود لما
انا كنت بقلمبيا بال 19
وبالاساي
وبال2 كان موجود بكلامبيا لسه الله يرحمه
ترك اثر عليك
من الناحيه الاكاديميه
هو مثقف مشتبك مع الحياه العامه مع
المجتمع الاكاديمي والثقافي في امريكا
يعني انا كطالبه اللي ادورت سعيد يعني
الطلاب اللي كنا ندرس الشرق الاوسط
والعلوم السياسيه والمنطقه العربيه انه
كنا كان انه يعني من يعني شغله احنا
اخذناها من ايام
الكولونيلزم بالشرق الاوسط انه لازم نتاسف
ونكون خجلانين انه احنا عرب واذا بدنا
نحكي عن مواضيعنا لازم لسا انه شوي شوي
نحكي عن مواضيعنا انه يعني زي الملناش حق
نحكي عن شعورنا واد سعيد اللي حطته فينا
احنا الطلاب انه خلانا نكون مفتخرين انه
عرب وبنقدر انه نعطي وجهه نظرنا اللي
مبنيه على الاختلافات يعني الخلفيات
تبعونا بدون ما نكون يعني مستحيل المشكله
الى الغرب نفسه هو طرح ان الاشكاليه في
الغرب وليس
الاشكاليه في الغرب طيب هذا دكتوره يطرح
فكره الفلسطيني الجيد والفلسطيني السيء في
المجتمع الامريكي مجتمع الثقافي
والاكاديمي وايضا العربي السيء والعربي
الجيد والمسلم السيء والمسلم يعني هناك
انفتاح حقيقي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يسمح باقليات بمهاجرين ان
يترقوا وانت اليوم عميده لي يعني هذه موقع
مو هذا موقع اكاديمي رفيع لكن هل تمت
الصوره يراد لها ان تكون ان يكون عليها
العربي والفلسطيني بمعنى هناك فلسطيني
مقبول وهناك فلسطيني غير مقبول يعني ليس
انا يعني
[موسيقى]
في امريكا ولكن لسه احنا بنشوف انه
المسلمين والعرب ليس في عنصريه تجاههم دون
يعني الاقليات الاخرى ليش لانه لسه في
للاسف الشديد مفهوم ضئيل جدا عن يعني عن
عن
معظم الامريكان لسا عمره ما شافوا عربي او
مسلم حقيقي قدامهم ولو انه فيه تقدم لسه
الميديا واثر الميديا وكيف بمثلوا العرب
والمسلمين وكيف بمثلوا الاختلافات هلا كل
ما بصير اي اشي يعني فلسطين ما بيقولوش
انه في قضيه فلسطينيه اسرائيليه مبنيه عن
سنين من الاختلاف وكان في شعب فلسطيني كذا
موجود وفي هالكيت يعني قضيه فلسطينيه
مستمره وحقوق الفلسطينيه مش متوفره بعلقوا
القضيه بالاسلام
وبالعنصريه
يعني كل المفاهيم عن المسلمين انه لانه
المسلمين كيك هيك هيك هيك هيك عندك القضيه
الفلسطينيه
والعرب اكثر سوءا من الاقليات الاخرى احنا
انا بالبحث بدي احكي بالانجليزي
لاي شخص انت عنصرين راح يقول لك لا لا احد
يقول ولا حدا راح يكون عن حاله مزبوط لانه
انه في طرق تسالها
بالاستطلاعات الراي تسال الاسئله غير
مباشره بتاخد نسبه العنصريه بالاسئله اوكي
فاحنا قررنا المسلمين مع اقليات تانيه
ولقينا انه العنصريه اتجاه المسلمين اعلى
اعلى من كل الاقليات التانيه اول شيء يعني
اكثر من اللاتيني اكثر من السود اكثر من
اي اي اقل الاسيويين
لان
عدم فهم جدا فقط عدم فهم فقط عدم فهم
وكمان يعني في طريقه هلا في تاريخ
يعني انا في الكتاب
اللي كانت تبعي يعني علاقه الغرب مع الشرق
الاوسط اراكم مميزه يعني عندك يعني في
يعني العلاقه مبنيه انه على
انها بتفيد الغرب
فوائد لازم يكون في التبرير انه ليش
امريكا موجوده في الدول العربيه ليش فيها
الحروب ليش فيها الشؤون
في هذه العلاقه المميزه ادت الى انه يعني
عدم المفاهيم عن الحياه والسياسه العربيه
والاسلاميه لما احنا بنحكي عن حروب يعني
بلا مؤاخذه بكون الجذور تبع الحروب لها
سنين الهام كرون ولكن ايش بيركزوا انه اوه
الولد هذا الصغير سوى كذا ولا يعني بركزوا
على مش على التاريخ ايش المفاتيح الاساسيه
او القضايا الاساسيه التي ترفع منسوب
العنصريه ضد العرب والمسلمين تحديدا يعني
شوف في عندك انت عنا شوف احداث سبتمبر
احداث سبتمبر مضبوط مسلمين كذا مزبوط في
تشويه للاسلام في الدول العربيه بس احنا
في امريكا في كمان
لما اذا انت بتاخذ الدفنشن
[موسيقى]
اوكي
انه احنا متفقين عليها
نسبه
الارهاب اللي بتصير من غير مسلمين يعني
تاخذ نسبه بتصير من المسلمين وغير
المسلمين في امريكا
اهتمام حجم الاهتمام والتركيز الاعلامي
على كل انسداد بتلاقي اذا كان المسلم
ارتكب الجريمه الميديا بتركز عليها حوالي
اربع خمس مرات اضعاف خمس اضعف من بعدين
لما لما يصير الحادث مرتبط بمسلم يكون
ارهاب لكن لما يكون بمسيحي غير مسلم يكون
جريمه جريمه حتى مصطلحات
يعني كان عندهم
بس المسلم بيضل مشان لانه مسلم
وبتبعد لانه مساله لها علاقه بالدين ولو
انه الشخص عمره ما صلى ولا عمره بفهم
بالقران
في الجامعه الامريكيه طبعا يعني شوف فيك
منك كثير احنا يعني انه بنشوف حالنا انه
يعني علينا واجب انه نعلم ونخلي الناس
تفهم شو الوضع مضبوط في اكاديميه يعني عرب
وغير عرب ما يعني ما عندهمش هذه الديسك
حجم تاثير العرب في المجتمع الاكاديمي
محدود ضئيل جدا بس قياسا على اسماء مثل
ادوار سعيد واسماء لاحقه كان كان نوعي كان
نوعي كان نوعي كان لهم تاثير كبير
بس يعني انه كان
يعني
في جمهور معين ومحدد يهتم بقضايا الشرق
الاوسط
بعد سنه في كولومبيا
هم هم كان عندهم اوبنه قالوا لي شو رايك
تعبي على على
الجامعه كنت انا لسه بلشت في الجديده
كنا احنا المضبوط ساكنين في نيوجيرسي
فقريبه اقرب على
وطبعا يعني انا كان عندي اولاد صغار
وكانوا بسن المدارس والمدارس هان كانت
يعني افضل من مش انه يعني
[موسيقى]
كل يوم فكان المشوار كمان تعب
كانت مساله شخصيه ماذا يعني ان يكون
الانسان استاذا العلوم السياسيه في
اولها تعرف كنت استاذن مساعده
فكان اول هدول الست سبع سنين من حياتي كان
بس كل يوم اجي ادرس اشوف الطلاب اسوي شغلي
وارجع دستور
لا توجد عثره تواجه العرب والمسلمين
المقيمين في الغرب اكبر من تلك الصوره
النمطيه المتخيله عنهم والتي تكرست عبر
عقود من العمل السينمائي والاعلامي وفي
حين حملت هوليود لنحو 80 عاما لواء تلك
الصوره المنتزه حينا والمشوهه احيانا اخرى
فان الاعلام الامريكي خصوصا والغربي عموما
بشقيه الصحفي والتلفزيوني بات يزاحمها في
حمل ذلك اللواء يدا بيد وهي مهمه اطلع بها
بعد احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
وجد اليمين الامريكي والغربي في تلك
الصوره معينا له في تسويق جانب من رؤيته
القاضيه بوجود تعارض بين الاسلام من جهه
والحريه والديمقراطيه والحداثه والقيم
الكونيه من جهه اخرى وتقول دراسات تناولت
صوره الاسلام والمسلمين لدى الامريكيين ان
تلك الصوره لم تخرج عن سرديات اعلاميه
ثلاث
سرديه الاتهام التي تعززت عبر جماعات
اليمين للتمييز بين الانا الجماعيه
البيضاء والاخر المسلم المنحرف عن مسار
الهويه والقيم الامريكيه المعاصره وثانيها
سرديه معياريه تعاملت مع المسلمين
الامريكيين كمكون عضوي داخل المجتمع
الامريكي اما اخرها فسرديه وصفيه تبنت
الحياد ووفق الدراسه فقد تسببت تكرار
الخطاب غير الموضعي لبعض وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه في ميلان الخطاب العام نحو
اليمين والتخلي التدريجي عن قيم التسامح
والتعدديه والانفتاح على العالم لصالح
دعوات التمييز العنصري وبدا جليل ان بعض
وسائل الاعلام تعاملت مع الاسلام
والمسلمين بشكل يختلف عن تعاملها مع فئات
اجتماعيه ودينيه وعرقيه اخرى
عن ماذا تركزت ابحاثك يعني اول ما تعينتك
استاذه في ان كان على التنميه السياسيه في
الشرق الاوسط
ماذا يعني ان تدرسي في مسار السياسه في
الشرق الاوسط لديك كلمه شهيره حول هذا
الامر يعني يعني هم اخر غير هم الاكاديمي
يعني كان انه يعني كنت ادرس وانا
كنت ابلش اعطي لقطه من فيلم
مشوه صوره العرب والمسلمين كومبليت لانه
كل هالعرب بيسيحوا مجانين وخلي الطلاب
يتفرج عليها واقف الفيديو واكلهم احكوا لي
شو انتم شفتوا
وكنا وبعدين يعني
في مساله العنصريه هل تشعرين انه انه في
تراجع في هذه المساله ام هل يبدو ان
الولايات المتحده في طريقها للتخلص مجتمع
المهاجرين مجتمع منوع متعدد يقبل الاخر من
حيث المبدا يعني في سيره انا عندي في ثيره
بالعلوم السياسيه مضبوط انه بيقولوا لك
انه
لما بيكونوا في امغرانس بيجوا على بلد
وبيكون في انصريه تجاههم يعني انه لما
هالايام يتعلموا ويتفوقوا ويشتغلوا
ويصيروا من المجتمع
العنصريه بتخف وفي سيره ثانيه بقول لك لا
بالعكس لما هالاقليات تيجي على الدول
وبتتعلم وبتصير وبتصيروا دكاتره وبيصيروا
مهندسين بيزيد عنصريه
اخذوا كل البلد هذول صار لهم راي
[موسيقى]
فانا كنت دائما من النوع اللي كنت اؤيد
الاول سيري انه مع التعليم مع
السميليشن انه بتخف العنصريه الا لما
على اخذ الرئاسه وكان العنصريه ضد
المسلمين رهيبه لما يعني السبريم كورد
وافقوا انه يصير مسلم بان يعني كتير بجوز
صرت انا يعني معتقد انه سكن سيري لانه
المشكله المشكله ليش السكن فيري انه
المشكله
يعني ما كانش السبب انه شخص يعني كان هو
عنده عنصريه التاييد ورا داون كثير كثير
عاليه وهذا اللي كان احنا يعني احنا
كاكاديميين لما اتضح لنا انه نسبه السبورت
لل باليس
بالاخص اتجاه المسلمين
كانت يعني مدعاه حزن وخوف وقلق وقلق يعني
وهو يحكي عن العنصريه ضد المسلمين الناس
يسقفوله ويعني مبسوطين
هل تعتقد ان العربي والمسلم والفلسطيني
اليوم يجلس على الطاوله طبعا لا انت هلا
هلا يعني
في كثير انحاء من في الحكومه في الجامعات
في
المحاميه
مهندسين الحمد لله يعني احنا الشعب العربي
الاسلاميه لانه طلعنا من بلداننا يعني
الحمد لله يعني عنا مشاكل بديش وكل عربي
مزبط وما شاء الله عنه يعني نكون بس ان
جنرال ايفن
المسلم في امريكا بتقول لك نسبه التعليم
نسبه التعليم
باللعبه
اكثر من نسبه التعليم
يعني بالجنوب
في الاقليات الاخرى الاقليات الاخرى يعني
بجوز هلا بيقول اميركنس بجوز مع المسلمين
ولا شوي اعلى بس
هل في تنسيق بين يعني هل في كومنتي تجمعات
نتورك شبكات عربيه في المجتمعات
الاكاديميه والثقافيه لانه ايضا تاثيرها
كبير
دراسات الشرق الاوسط
ميسم
لما كنا ندرس عن احوال المجتمع العربي في
امريكا في
يعني عندك اساسي
يعني متعلقه بالدراسات بس انه في كمان
مؤسسات
يعني بتضمن المسلمين او العرب كمان
في موجود في كل انحاء يعني عندك
المحاميين في
مسلمات
احنا نتحدث عن دكتوره اماني انها واحده من
افضل جامعات كيف تكون الجامعه من افضل
الجامعات ما هي المعايير التي تجعل من
الجامعه في مراكز متقدمه
هذا السؤال مهم جدا احنا كتير مفتخرين
بهذا يعني واحنا الله يخليك احنا مفتخرين
الله يخليك فيكم ما شاء الله يعني اذا بدي
لما كنت بقول بدهم يجوا الجزيره
وبيعرفوا الجزيره قلت لهم اذا انت بتعرفوا
يعني الجزيره
الحمد لله الحمد لله كيف تكون الجامع من
معايير التي تجعل من الجامعه الافضل من
بين الجامعات الاخرى
بحياتهم فبالتالي اول قياس المخرجات
المخرجات في رؤساء طلعوا من رئيس
اثنين بس كمان يعني العديد انا هلا لما
صرت انا العميد المدرسه وبروحه
الحكومه في كل انحاء الدي سي بتشوف انه
ايش طلابه تخرج في الحكومه ناثر في
الجامعات
يتفضل الاحسن الجميع
اين تذهب المخرجات كمان بتطلعوا انه طيب
هل طلاب
الاساتذه
مع الطلاب في المحاضرات في المحاضرات في
احنا هون في يعني بجوز من
امه
اللي احنا الكاسات
طويل مع الطلاب عبر ساعات محدده وساعات
محدده المفروض علينا
الطلاب الدكتوراه بعلموا احنا لازم كمان
نعلم
البحث العلمي البحث العلمي طبعا كل طالب
بتخرج كل ما يتخرج لازم يكتب سيسي اللي هي
حوالي يعني 100 صفحه ونص لايك بي اتش دي
في
لازم يكتبها ومبنيه على الاصلي وبالتالي
ايضا بكالوريوس باحثين باحثين طيب
[موسيقى]
لو قارنا بين التعليم الجامعي هنا والعالم
العربي نتحدث عن فوارق شاسعه في فوارق
كبير
او للاسف الشديد يعني يعني للاسف الشديد
يعني انا سويت بحث مع الامد ايست مره عن
الدراسه
لكن يعني مش للاسف الشديد انه الطلاب كتير
اذكياء وكثير عندهم طموح وكثير حابين يعني
يتعلموا بس المجالات التعليميه
في معظم الجامعات بالشرق الاوسط
لا تقدم لهم ماذا يتطلعون او ما يريدونه
بشكل كبير دكتور اماني انا سعيد جدا هذا
الجزء الاول من لقائنا معك في الجزء
الثاني ساتحدث عن كتبك واهتمامك
بالديمقراطيه وعلاقه الديمقراطيه يعني
ايضا في
بالمجتمع المدني وما انتجتي من كتب ومساله
الامبراطور الولايات المتحده والتاثيرها
على الديمقراطيه في العالم انا شاكر وم
جدا وجودك معنا في هذه الحلقه الاولى وان
شاء الله تكونين معنا في الحلقه الثانيه
شكرا مشاهدينا الكرام شكرا لكم على طيب
المتابعه القاكم ان شاء الله الاسبوع
المقبل مع حلقه جديده مع الدكتوره اماني
جمال ايضا حول مزيد من القضايا المتعلقه
بالديمقراطيه وكذلك
الاستطلاعات الكثيره والكبيره التي اجرتها
الدكتوره عبر مشروع الباروميتر العربي
ومواقف
المواطنين بشكل عام واتجاهاتهم في مساله
الديمقراطيه وتاثير بلد مثل الولايات
المتحده على مسار الديمقراطيه في العالم
العربي شكرا لكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]